every great anime needs a supreme evil
Organization for the hero to defeat by
the end of the story and in one piece
that big bad guy is the entire world
government and Marine system which let
me tell you this system is so massive
and complex with tons of important
characters good neutral and evil that
it's sometimes incredibly difficult to
even know if they're gonna be the final
boss of the series or just a group that
we actually might be rooting for at the
end and so if all of this feels a little
bit confusing for you as well I'm going
to explain in detail how this entire
organization actually works and it all
begins with the surprising fact that the
Marines as a whole are actually not all
that bad because one thing to keep in
mind about this group is that it is
absolutely enormous I think people
really don't understand this and while
we don't have official numbers there are
most likely hundreds of thousands if not
millions of Marines who work hard to
keep the peas around an entire planets
because despite all of the legendary
clashes that we see in the main story
and of course the grand line the Marines
primary role is actually to protect the
170 Island kingdoms that are actually
officially part of the world government
and all of these kingdoms have to pay a
tax called The Heavenly tribute to the
world Nobles to keep the protections
from the world government and the
Marines plus they kind of get to vote on
some things which we will discuss more
about later on but the Marines are
actually incredibly necessary and
important for just your average Joe of
the one piece world because if you live
on some random island in the ocean you
probably don't have that many strong
fighters to protect yourself so actually
having the Marines around to fight off
evil Pirates is 100 a good thing overall
which actually does make it incredibly
ironic that we mostly get to see the
Marines as bad guys because our main
character Luffy fights against them and
mostly also the most corrupt ones
however we do have to keep in mind that
Luffy is a pirate and it's the Marine's
job to actually protect the world from
Pirates I mean really just think about
it for a minute almost everywhere Luffy
goes he gets into gigantic fights that
leave a huge mess for the island to
clean up afterwards that we just never
get to see and so if you're just a
regular citizen or marine and you don't
know the true reasons why Luffy was
fighting there you'd probably just think
he was one of the most evil guys in the
world as well so yeah that's the basic
job of the Marines protect people from
Pirates and this is true basically
everywhere in the world except for the
grand line where many islands are mostly
ruled by Pirates which again we'll
discuss more a little bit later on but
how does the system actually work well
to properly explain this we have to work
our way up through the different Marine
ranks so imagine you are a good-hearted
person who just really from the bottom
of your heart wants to help make the
world a better and safer place kind of
like Kobe right here and so to sign up
you probably have to go to your local
Marine base which are scattered
literally all across all of the oceans
of the world and unless you're already a
super well-known or very powerful
individual you will more than likely be
starting out at the very bottom rank as
a chore boy which means that you'll
probably be spending a fairly good
amount of time on a random Marine base
or ship just really helping out with the
basic chores not even any fighting but
then after some time if you do show some
fighting capabilities you might be
promoted to semen recruit which means
that you're now a common soldier in the
Marines and so now instead of wiping
decks or carrying stuff around you are
now actually thrown onto the front lines
of big battles to defend the people in
your territory and let's really just
hope you don't get one shot by literally
anyone strong out there I guess what
you'd kind of call General fodder now
this is each Marine's basic job all the
way up to the Seaman Apprentice rank
semen first class and Eve even into the
different Paddy and warrant officer
ranks but as you move more and more up
you'll probably get more and more
responsibilities and Men you actually
command such as communicating orders to
lower ranked soldiers and hopefully
there are some benefits as well here in
fact the very first time that we
actually meeted this black-haired swords
woman who surprisingly looks quite a lot
like Zara's childhood friend quina she
is a master chief petty officer who
works directly under a marine Captain
which makes her second in command of the
entire Marine base in the loketown which
is quite impressive and so just like
toshigi here which is her name you can
have a ton of responsibility even before
you ever become a captain at least
that's in the four blue Seas where the
Marines are typically a little bit lower
ranked until they're promoted to the
actual Grand line although who knows
maybe it's actually a good thing to stay
around here because as we'll see in just
a moment the higher you rise in rank the
more corrupt the organization becomes
but let's now jump into the actual
commissioned off officers starting off
with enzyme officer rank now we're going
to stick with toshigi for this rank
because when we saw her back during the
post and his Lobby Arc she had recently
actually been promoted to just this rank
which to be fair I'm not sure how much
Authority this gave her but I'd assume
that she can at least give orders to a
larger group of Marines and they likely
have a certain area of the sea to patrol
as well Plus on top of this she is in
the grand line now so the average pirate
she will fight is way stronger than on
base level all around the world and
that's clearly what we see her doing
most of the time because it looks like
she and her allies just finished
protecting an island from a group of
pirates but that still doesn't mean that
at this rank she has much freedom to
make her own choices in the Marine so if
you want to actually have some level of
Independence and freedom to choose stuff
how high do you actually need to go in
this organization well let's skip ahead
to the rank of Captain and see how great
having some Independence actually turns
out to be because it is at this exact
rank that many captains actually get to
control their very own Marine base which
can be an absolute disaster for people
living around the base for example the
very first captain that we meet in the
story is this ax-handed captain of the
153rd Marine Branch but this dude was
literally evil he would heavily tax the
villagers was very corrupt execute
people for talking back to his son and
build giant statues of himself just to
satisfy his pride and if you're thinking
that that's the only random example of a
corrupt captain in one piece well
there's also this cat face Captain who
was supposed to help free nami's Village
from the evil Fishman crew but instead
just accepted a major bribe and stole
all of nami's hard-earned money instead
well yeah wow these guys are just plain
awful which might make you wonder how
they even got their ranks in the first
place well as we'll say later on the
only thing that really matters to
Marines is your fighting strength
apparently so as long as you can prove
yourself to some degree in combat you
will probably keep Rising through the
Marine ranks which is a really stupidly
messed up system if we're being honest
but captains can also be out on patrol
instead of having their own base and in
the grand line the rank of Captain is
basically the lowest ranked Marine who
can put up a decent fight against a
somewhat important Pirates because
really anyone below Captain basically
gets completely washed at a certain
level by every pirate which does now
bring us to Commodores which is the rank
just below the all-important Admiral
type ranks now normally these marines
here are just higher ranking captains
who have similar duties but there are a
few notable Commodores who deal with
special matters that are way too
important for lower ranked Marines for
example this Commodore here is in charge
of assigning bounces to Pirates all
across the world however they still lack
the freedom of higher ranking Marines as
we saw when this chain smoking Marine
was a Commodore and he complained that
he still needed a higher rank to
actually accomplish his goal of chasing
the straw hats into the new worlds but
now we're actually getting to a whole
new tier of Marines with the rank of
rare Admiral now this rank we're well
past your common Marines because these
characters are fighters who can be
trusted to hold their own against strong
pirates for example this ruthless lady
Marine is now a rear Admiral as is this
clay using Marine that we actually just
recently met in the manga who has
command of one of the most important
Marine bases that is located right next
to many of the yonko territories in the
new world however even these strong rear
Admirals are nothing compared to this
next rank which is of course that of
vice admiral not only is this the rank
with the most currently known members in
the story but they're essentially the
group of Marines trusted with special
missions such as when this guy was sent
to bring the pirate Empress to Marine
for it and they were the largest group
of strong Marines during the war at
Marine Fort as well also Vice Admirals
are in charge of massive fleets of
Marine battleships which we see put to
devastating effect when five wise
Admirals are sent on a buster call
mission on Anna's Lobby on top of that
Vice ad rods are also the first rank to
actually have a very decent degree of
flexibility and freedom for example when
this smoking dude finally achieves this
rank he can finally fulfill his wish of
chasing after the straw hats freely then
of course we have the hero of the Marine
Luffy's grandfather GARP who basically
does whatever he wants as a vice admiral
although we do see him following some
orders from time to time occasionally
such as when he escorted the Fishman
royalty to the meeting of the world
rulers and interestingly Vice Admirals
are confirmed to be quite excellent
Fighters many of them have devil fruits
but it is also officially confirmed that
all of them know at least some form of
hockey as well but with all of that
being said usually there are literal
galaxies of differences between the vice
Admirals and the next rank which is of
course the the Admiral tier which you
can take a shortcut to by subscribing to
the channel for more one piece content
just like this and seriously though the
Admirals are commonly referred to as the
greatest power in the Marines and for a
very good reason to be promoted to the
rank of an admiral means that you are
one of the literal strongest fighters in
the entire world in fact there are only
ever three of these positions at one
time and we've seen throughout the story
that these marines are just
devastatingly powerful in fight and
possess some of the most broken devil
fruits as well for example Admirals like
the light producer kizaru have nearly
killed Luffy multiple times and even the
former Admiral aokiji easily defeated
Luffy as well so these dudes are really
not people you should mess around with
in fact they're really more monsters
than people at this point they do have a
ton of responsibility as well though as
they're essentially the Bodyguards of
the world Nobles who would talk about
more in just a moment and whenever there
is a yonko level threat the Admirals are
the ones who are actually sent in to
deal with that problem each Admiral also
has their very own personal style of
Justice which influences the actions
that they take for example aokiji's
Justice is lazy Justice which means that
he will sometimes follow orders and
other times kind of do what he thinks is
best for example we kind of saw this
when he allowed Robin to escape after
the destruction of her own Island and
even later on after she escaped with the
straw hats also the Admirals all kind of
followed that color Animal theme so you
have the yellow monkey kizaru Red Dog
blue pheasant and so on and so forth
however there is one even higher rank in
the Marines than the Admirals and that
is the position of Fleet Admiral which
if I'm being completely honest I
personally don't think that I would want
to have this job at all because even the
super aggressive kind of combat loving
magma fruit using a kainu went from
being this one-man Army kind of thing as
an admiral to being just a pencil
pushing administrator ever since he got
his promotion to Fleet Admiral although
he does get to set the actual main
philosophy of the Marines which in this
case means that the Marines now follow
akinu's absolute Justice and this change
in philosophy compared to the previous
lead Admiral sengoku means that now the
entire Marine organization is a lot more
Cutthroat and willing to do whatever it
takes to just straight out kill Pirates
even if it requires some truly evil
things along the way and altogether this
is actually the main structure of the
Marines but you might be surprised to
know that they are just the one single
pillar of what makes up the entire world
government military forces and that's
because there are actually two other
super important branches of the military
that affect the world in different ways
and the first of these are the legendary
Cipher pole agencies whose main job
involves investigation spying and yeah
assassinations now currently there are
six known Cypher pull groups the most
known of these is of course cp9 who wear
the straw Hat's main enemies during the
water 7 and nslobby arcs and this
particular group specialized in
assassinations but they were also secret
agents who spent years working
undercover to find the blueprints to the
ancient weapon pluton on water 7. but
that's not even the strongest group
though because after the time skip we
were introduced to zp9 which if I'm
being honest is essentially made up of
mostly the old cp9 agents and what's
special about this group is that they
work directly for the world Nobles which
if you know anything about those
scumbags then you should know that they
are up to no Goods in fact we've even
seen some of these single shadiest
dealings of the world government
directly involving cp0 for example when
they were negotiating with the evil
Shogun of wano and the literal yonko
kaido to buy weapons from them and when
they were buying literal orphans from
this old lady to train him to become
government agents as well and so clearly
this branch of the world government has
a lot more to do with the corruption and
evil nature of the entire system than
the first group that we've talked about
before but that's not even the worst
part though because the other main
pillar of the world government forces is
the entire warlord system and let me
tell you that this system was just
completely messed up right from the
start now if you don't know the way that
this works is that the World Government
invited certain Pirates to work with
them and so once a pirate becomes a
warlord they basically get to do
whatever they want without any
consequences being free from the Marines
for example the warlord's crocodile Endo
Flamingo essentially decided to take
over entire kingdoms but the Marines
were restricted from doing anything to
stop them however in exchange for this
level of Freedom the Warlords then must
fight for the world government whenever
they're being called upon and we really
only ever saw this happen once in the
story during the war at Marine Ford
where the Warlords actually had to help
the Marines fight against the emperor
Whitebeard and of course this is the
perfect time to also mention that the
Marines the Warlords and the yonko make
up what is the so-called three power
system of the one piece world and the
idea here is that the combined strength
of the Marines and the Warlords kind of
helps balance out the immense power of
the Emperors and with this balance the
strongest Pirates usually end up staying
within their territories in the grand
line which keeps the world from being
thrown completely into chaos which
worked out somewhat well let's say until
the warlord system was just completely
thrown in the garbage because of the
awful things that some of the Warlords
had done but that system was then
quickly replaced by the new special
science Group which is made up of some
of the most insane technology the world
has ever seen and that's because the
genius scientists of the world
government has invented an entire Army
of super strong cyborgs who can shoot
laser beams plus there are now these
Ultra powerful clones that have devil
fruit powers and basically cannot be
destroyed and so with all of this
incredibly destructive technology the
world government is a bigger threat now
than ever before Oh and actually there's
one other special group within the
Marines that we haven't talked about yet
this group is called sword and they are
Marines who have officially given up the
Marine status but who still work towards
the overall good of the Marine
organization really the only difference
is that they are not restricted by
Marine orders or orders from higher up
but that unfortunately also means that a
sword member will not be saved by the
Marines if they ever get into trouble
that was by the way perfectly shown by
this sword member who went undercover as
a pirate joined an Emperor's crew but
then turned against kaido when the straw
hats came to defeat the emperor during
the wano arc and every single group that
I just mentioned is directly under the
control of this guy here who you might
have never seen before who is actually
the Commander in Chief of the world
governments which does mean that he can
basically give orders to anyone who
works for the government Marine Special
Aid regions anything but his main role
is actually to act as a kind of
go-between for the military forces and
the actual World Nobles and I mean can
you even imagine the insane amount of
just ridiculous requests that this man
must be getting from the world Nobles
because if the entire group of world
novels are just half as crazy as the
ones we've already met then they have
got to be the most selfish idiotic
spoiled group of individuals on the
entire planets which you might be
wondering how is it even possible that
these people came to be in charge of the
world in the first place well the answer
is that these people are the descendants
of the original 20 kingdoms who ended up
founding the world government
organization over 800 years ago after
the so-called void century and since
that time the world Nobles have lived up
on the top of the red line where they
hold absolute power over the world and
here we get into really dark territory
because this includes the freedom to
keep slaves kidnap murder and waste
stupid amount of money on ridiculous
things with literally zero consequences
they can also give any order to the
Marines and Cipher pole plus they are
protected everywhere they go nonetheless
surprisingly we found out that they do
seem to actually have some of their own
laws that they must obey and follow as
well and we only know that because
recently in the manga we were introduced
to a brand new group of government
soldiers called The Holy Knights of gods
and this specific group seems to be made
up of super powerful World Nobles who
have the power to enforce Justice even
among themselves which we can clearly
see when they even kill and crucify one
of their own for a certain crime which
honestly it seemed impossible that
something like this could happen to the
Untouchable figures but these holy
nights are not even the highest ranking
World Nobles out there and that's
because the main group of nobles that we
always see making big decisions for the
entire world are these five old men
right here these are the so-called Gordo
say often translated as the five Elder
Stars though as we now know it's more
likely that it's actually the five Elder
planets and of course this is where the
corruption of the world government truly
starts running deep because this group
uses all the military forces of the
world government to protect their
deepest and darkest Secrets which we'll
be talking about in just a moment first
though we do have to ask just who are
these five old men well for one we do
know that they are actual World Nobles
although unlike the rest they don't wear
these ridiculous spacesuits and helmets
plus we only quite recently learned
their names and their official
government duties in the manga and we
also don't know how they were chosen to
be part of the gorose in the first place
but the most important question that is
still unanswered is if they have
actually been alive ever since the world
government was formed 800 years ago and
that's because I mean the way they talk
sometimes really makes it seem like
they've been alive for a long time kind
of as Immortal Gods who just view the
races and Wars of the world world as
playthings but then again if they
actually are Immortal then surely
someone would have noticed if these
dudes ever aged since they are sometimes
seen meeting with other people however
that's not even the most mysterious part
about them because as we've been shown
throughout the entire story The Guru say
will do anything to protect the secrets
of the Void Century now if you don't
know this is a time period that occurred
between nine and 800 years ago but all
history of it has been literally erased
from the entire world that means there
is no mention of anything during this
time however there is one big big
exception to this and that is these
unbreakable Stone writings called
pornoglyphs which actually record the
true history of the Void century plus
they do Point towards the direction of
Love Tale the final Island which does
contain the one piece treasure so yeah
these things are a serious problem for
the gorosei which makes it a little bit
odd that after 800 years they still
haven't managed to go around and collect
all of these stones but whatever the
true history actually is it will
probably not be as shocking as the
ultimate power of the world government
by the way a major spoiler warning here
if you aren't quite caught up to the
latest start of the wano arc but in
chapter 906 of the manga it was revealed
that there is actually a secret ruler of
the world governments named emu who can
make even the gurusi the highest of the
highest bow down and listen to their
orders so uh yeah you heard that right
seriously there is a mysterious person
who literally has all the power if emo
wants a nearby Kingdom literally wiped
off the map they do it if emo wants a
certain princess of a kingdom to be
kidnapped it is done they literally have
control over everything and everyone and
so funnily enough what is supposed to be
a government where 170 kingdoms from all
across the world come together every
four years to vote on important issues
is in truth control by the world Nobles
who again are just puppets for this
mysterious figure who we are still
waiting to learn a lot more about you
can really kind of think about it like a
bad apple where on the outside it looks
very pretty delicious and shiny just
like most of the Marines are actual good
people but once you get to the inside of
the Apple it turns out it is completely
rotten to the core literally but wait
even though we've now reached the
literal top of the world government
structure there are still some other
really really important details that we
need to mention the first is that the
government also controls the justice
system which does include the Justice
island of anislavi where criminals are
tried in court which is completely
corrupt by the way before being then
sent to the underwater prison imple down
and as you can see during the imple down
Arc this is where the worst Pirates and
criminals are sent to be tortured
literally until they die nice also I did
already mention the founding of the
world government in passing but it's
worth spending a little bit more time on
because this history is absolutely going
to play a major role in the final Saga
of the story that's because from the
little that we already know there was a
major war way back during the void
century and during that war the original
20 kingdoms of the world government
fought against an unknown group that was
most likely led by the legendary figure
Joy boy which if you've been on the
internet at all recently you probably
already know that Luffy has now
inherited the title of Joy boy so we
simply must learn more about this time
period and how the world government
actually gained their powers because I
mean if they've spent so much time and
effort keeping the information hidden it
must be something incredibly dark that
they absolutely don't want the world to
know plus what's maybe even crazier is
that we also recently learned that the
one piece World used to be way more
technologically advanced than it is
right now in fact the world had giant
robots lasers cloning technology
possibly space travel and way way more
awesome stuff that the world is only now
starting to really learn how to do and
so really there must be some really
really big reason why the world
government wanted to send the world back
to basically the Stone Age when they
began their rule 800 years ago and on
top of that there of course also is the
secrets of the devil fruits which are
probably also somehow tied to this time
period so I simply cannot wait for all
these secrets to be revealed to the
world but we of course cannot mention
the world government and Marines without
also bringing up the main groups who
oppose them there are of course Pirates
like Luffy and the yonko who have major
influence throughout the world but
honestly these groups aren't seriously
trying to take each other out they only
sometimes come into major conflicts like
during Marine Forts and so much more
importantly there is the Revolutionary
Army led by Luffy's father Dragon whose
sole mission is to take down the corrupt
World Nobles which the specific wording
of this is actually important because
they don't actually want to destroy the
Marines just the evil rulers who sit at
the top of it all and in fact only quite
recently have they actually gone head to
head against the world government in a
fight and declared war because for most
of the story The Revolutionary Army has
been focused on convincing kingdoms all
around the globe to leave the government
and join their Revolution which is
exactly the reason why this Kingdom from
earlier got completely wiped off the map
and with this weapon capable of
destroying islands in the world
government's hands it's going to take a
ton of Firepower to eventually actually
defeat him but luckily the one piece
world has one of the most impressive
Power Systems in all of anime with a
huge variety of powers like hockey devil
fruit science and even much much more so
if you want a complete breakdown of the
incredible and complex power system of
One Piece you can watch the entire
breakdown right here thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one